I got you
oh God spit it out
wow oh God so much pride there's no
cheese in this like there's no cheese in
this that is the most that is that boy
we have the one that's aerosol like you
have the like the the spray which sounds
worse but like my spray cheese uh okay
so this is real cheese so that is real
Cheddar okay let's just say that way
oh that's delicious so in the US what do
you serve that with like what would you
put it on
um depression yeah I was gonna say
depression regret oh
that's a donut right there
I'm brave there's a there's a mineral
yeah I was gonna say what's the
ingredients of this thing because it's
like no it's not cheese there's no
cheese ingredient in that